people of the internet hello and welcome
back to the final episode of our dark
arts playthrough of Hogwarts Legacy you
guys already know I'm just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
pretty confident that we are going to
finish off the game today we have this
Quest coming up need to visit Mr
Ollivander in his shop and see if he can
craft the Keeper's wand with the
artifacts I acquired from their trials
that is the main mission however
we cannot complete the playthrough
without this one right here in the
shadow of the Relic you guys see the
rewards over there you see the rewards
Avada Kedavra now it is suggesting our
level
as level 28. so I'm hoping it won't be a
problem that we
don't man maybe I should do one more
because we're actually I think we're
pretty close to level 28. oh yeah we're
so close
so close to level 28 maybe we should
just do a little side quest first and
just to make sure that we are absolutely
let's find one that's like
oh wait purchase a broom upgrade from
Alby weeks okay that should be pretty
easy one to do by the way uh if you guys
are checking this out and you're new I
don't know why you'd be watching the
last episode and be new but hey welcome
in we do stream this live over on Twitch
twitch.tv retro wrecking tour you will
hear me
interacting with the chat throughout the
day throughout the episode here
and we're also going to be talking about
drops every now and then so if you are
watching this before I think like June
1st
then you can still hop over and get the
free cosmetic drop so this is something
that Avalanche is doing in partnership
with twitch
and all you have to do is watch the
stream for any of you here watching live
right now it is exclamation point drops
in the chat we'll get you the
information you need
[Music]
and I think we'll level up by just doing
this right here
hey I appreciate it Matt I appreciate it
we said the thing guys yeah we said the
thing we have to say the thing whenever
it's
gonna be a let's play Style video
all right so let's go ahead and sell
some of this stuff to him as well
and one more thing we could do before we
go
for the final final mission
is we'll want to upgrade our gear and
stuff
all right so this is not what I thought
we just bought the upgrade we didn't
actually let's see did we actually
complete anything with that you're all
set with the new upgrade I mean because
it should you should complete the quest
this might sound presumptuous but you
like me to report back with even more
flight details
the South Coast course we could knock
out the time trial do you really what
with rumors of ramrock's lot and
ashwinder zimfil trait in the place
however if you're flying high above them
you should be all right I think
they don't scare me that's the weeks
I'll see if I can find Imelda I hope you
are able to complete these trials baby
diamond girl with the follow thank you
thank you you're welcome in success do
be careful of course I shall look
forward to hearing from you soon
I look forward to our next meeting
oh come on check off that Quest
darn it it didn't complete anything it's
not when you upgrade on the way
yeah let's go I mean I know the
Ollivander
once you start that doesn't it
Propel you to the end game pretty
quickly
I'm trying to remember exactly how it
plays out with that
because I know you do that and then I
think right after that is when I just
saw something wait what's going on here
why is that why did that marker pop up
all of a sudden
come on in healing potions especially
something should you need any
oh did I actually do that I delivered
the potions I don't remember doing that
very good and uh did she cause you any
trouble
she's difficult very difficult she
didn't want to go she was quite
difficult very much I truly appreciate
your help and at least it's done with
I'd like an additional fee his potions
was a bit more work than I'd expected
I'd like an additional fee I suppose
that's business for you
really well I shall increase your page
they actually increase it for you with
your potions Mr Pepin no way
it's still showing up that I could oh
okay we got 180 XP right there
all right that moved us a little bit
closer
a little bit closer to level 28 I mean
honestly we might be fine even if we
went in at level 27 and who knows we
could actually
oh my goodness
oh my goodness that is so far down here
all right let's go to this one right
here
yeah guys thank you all for being here
hanging out today on this Tuesday
afternoon
hope everyone is having a good day so
far
and if you have any questions about the
drops any questions about the game let
me know we are on our second playthrough
as an evil Slytherin on this playthrough
very very close to the end of the game
I'm just trying to hit Level 28 here
completing a couple of these other
missions
W Justice welcome in
thank you for being here hanging out
hope you're having a good day so far
all right I think this is the last
balloon
yep there we go okay that was only 50 XP
not very much but hey
we'll take it
the course looks rather deserted
hope everything's all right all right go
over here let's do this
hello again Imelda he pays you 300
standards 500 if you ask for more no way
evidently too far for most of our
classmates
all right come on let's do it Imelda I'm
just trying to I need to get my
experience
all right we're ready I think we can do
it right now
I'm ready get ready to lose
[Music]
nah we're not gonna lose
we are not gonna lose
it's going well
just have to start hitting those
oh my goodness Luna is whining all of a
sudden just out of nowhere
hold on we're in the middle of a broom
race
[Music]
and now we missed a few right there as
long as you keep keep hitting the yellow
orbs
can pretty much just hold down L2 the
whole time
for that extra speed
wasn't too difficult
she wanted out for some reason
oh thank you oh I missed one I was
looking away I missed it
Mrs raconteur bringing us some lunch
very kind of her
that's the one bad thing about starting
this early is I have to make sure I have
lunch plans set up before I start the
stream
now that's more like it
all right hopefully missing that one
ring won't
lose it for us
[Music]
no no no we need those
only got one right there
I haven't seen the
ghost
I call him ghosts you know it's like
from Mario Kart when you have your wow
ghost that goes around showing your best
time
because I think they add a little bit of
a penalty for me missing that that ring
[Music]
yeah this one's pretty tough there's a
lot of twists and turns on it
foreign
[Music]
yep there we go so we missed one
so yeah three second penalty
I still think we're good
let's find out that was quite something
impressive work today but don't get too
comfortable okay so we did your heels in
no time my family is not going to
believe the news when I tell them
they're almost as competitive as I am
almost
will you keep running these courses I'll
rest them myself
rust but I won't be dealing with time
trials you're welcome to run them too
anyway a magical find time to fly again
thank you for the three months my friend
appreciate it
enjoy your ad free viewing
and now you also get all the emotes all
right we're good how much money against
your records how much experience did
that give has been fun
glad you're here fifth year you're an
asset to our house
that's right that's right
all right let's see did that not give me
anything
I should let Mr weeks know that this was
his best upgrade yet because that's not
completing the quest yet right yeah
all right so we have to go back to our
buddy Alby weeks
back to hogsmead
you understood that reference now that's
room racing
is that now this is POD racing
is that what the reference is for
if it says flyer
will
you gonna come in here and ask
controversial question like that
come on will
the answer is heck no
no but I mean it's each zone right you
enjoy it go for it fantastic
I do not personally like pineapple and
pizza though no it flew beautifully
incredibly Nimble but with the speeds it
now reaches I can feel the wind catching
beneath the seat a bit preventing it
from reaching its full potential of
course should have anticipated that
exactly the kind of report I've come to
expect from you at last I think I know
what needs to be done for my final
upgrade I don't think he has it ready
ready right away though
I shall look forward to speaking again
I'll be sure to send you an hour when
I'm finished thank you again for your
help
couldn't have done this without you all
right we'll see does that give us
anything
yep 180 oh we're so close I missed the
weeks
I think one more thing
and will be level 28 which I don't think
you have to be level 28 to do it it's
kind of just like that's what they
recommend
so let's check our Quest page here what
would be
I mean honestly like this easy one with
just attend divination during the day
I think we should be able to
level up from that
because you only level up by completing
Field Guide things
so I don't know if there's a
something for that in the field guide or
not
let's find out
you ask every single hey it's all good
I'm just messing with you will
some people get very you know
they get very heated about that question
I'm just like whatever
I don't personally like it
I've had it before when I was a kid my
my parents actually
like it and get it occasionally
how have we not went by that blue flame
all this time
foreign
have a good one will thank you for
stopping by
all right we are here for our class
and we're gonna learn a new spell
[Music]
thank you
nice kitty yeah we had a bunch of gifted
Subs earlier
not sure who
who got you that one
but congrats
enjoy no ads on the stream when you have
the sub knowledgeable
all right now we have to go talk to you
those assignments were challenging
enough for you
I've completed all of my tasks Professor
Runway very well done although I must
admit I did have something overpriced
did you now that you would follow
through now as you have no doubt
sharpened your perception by completing
my assignment
I am curious based upon the knowledge
that one's present and even one's past
May reveal traces of what is to come
what do you see in your own future
hmm
I see Power I see good things
after all the Futures mine for the
taking
and I shall take what I must I see well
I knew that you and Sebastian spoken
like a true Slytherin but now you are
even beginning to like him I would only
crush on you be careful what you take
the future you carve out cannot be taken
back but this talk of tomorrow yeah
good Deputy headmistress of your
exemplary performance
if that performance is any Omen of what
your future may hold
then I for one see great things
Channel your magic towards your target
descendo
here we go
Justice uh you're resisting doing the
last Keeper's test to do the little
Quest thoughts no what do you mean like
is that a good strategy or
so the very final boss without spoiling
anything is is more difficult yeah but
I mean once you hit a certain point
you're you're gonna be fine you're gonna
be fine anyway
all right so we have
all right I have two accio set up
okay so this one let's change to
descendo
oh my goodness dude we gained XP but we
still
the final Albedo I'll be coming through
wait
this might be enough right here
come on 28.
oh my goodness dude
all right we should just be able to find
a field guide page somewhere
let's go back and talk to Alby I don't
know if talking to him one more time
completes anything or not
ancient magic hot spots yeah that's
definitely a good one to do
oh hello again couldn't have perfected
the broom upgrades without your help as
always I have a 7 500.
okay thankfully we just need to sell one
thing
oh wait we can sell that
I truly enjoyed working with you thank
you for believing in me come on upgrade
us
no that's not marked
it doesn't complete out the quest
Rebellion
all right let's find one revelio page
I think one revelio page should be
enough
dude did we already get them all in
hogsmeade let's check the map
oh wow we we did get quite a few 36 out
of 55.
I think we can definitely find
[Music]
no chime
maybe we can find a flying page
somewhere
oh I see it I see it
what
how have we not leveled up
okay wait wait we got another one here
if this doesn't do it
oh we might have to actually get inside
here
time quick yes there it is
that's right zonkos does have a couple
in there
all right
goodness it's only 80 XP it barely moved
hello
welcome to brood I'm actually gonna sell
I think I have
I think I have several animals we can
sell here
creatures what do you have for sale
now what's up what's up to buy products
might you be looking to acquire yeah
certain clients oh that's a shiny I'll
keep the shiny
I think this is a shiny too yep
um
all right
I will not mind seeing you here again
consider yourself oh yeah yeah yeah you
can get 100 after doing it justice
unless
unless the trophy bugs out on you like
it has done for me
but um no you can you can still go
around and do everything
and you will not have any
issues doing that all right I guess we
need to do one maybe two more
I think there's some in honeydukes as
well but I may have already gotten all
those
yep I think we did
all right zonkos where are you
where are you you think after all this
time playing the game I would know
exactly where everything is but
loots and loots
Rebellion
oh I heard a chime
okay here's zonko's I think there's one
in the upper level
I know there used to be one here yeah I
already got that one
is it down or up
let's try up first
finish writing your seventh book Shadow
guided wow that is awesome congrats
I think I mentioned to you before Shadow
guided I started
I started a book years and years ago and
still want to finish it one day
but I mean I was I was pretty pretty
good into it I mean over a hundred
thousand words
but just being able to complete
something complete one book
is an accomplishment but to complete
seven
that is incredible
Rebellion
here it is right there
all right come on that's gotta be it
right
take us to 28.
okay it took a second
finally all right there we go guys we
are officially level 28. which means we
are now according to the game strong
enough to attempt
Sebastian sallow in the shadow of the
Relic
talk to ominous at the catacomb
and guys this is a big one this is the
big one
let's go ahead and go to our map here
fast travel
and if you do not want to know the end
of Sebastian's questline
look away look away
tell him what lies in my because this
will be
full spoilers here
Sebastian has gone too far all right
here we go
you saw Hamlet and himself in danger on
the chance that some old Relic could
help to heal me
I'm sorry on this
make sure he's all right will you
I'm glad you're here
are you though
I received your owl where's Sebastian
inside the catacomb
frankly I was surprised you weren't with
him ominous stop
you did what you had to do and I agreed
it might well have salvaged my
friendship with Sebastian for the moment
you did agree and it did save your
he and the entire Hamlet are in danger
the place is crawling within theory in
theory
what are you talking about
you'll see
we need to hurry you'll see
Sebastian must not be in his right mind
all right guys
into the catacomb we go last time we
were here this place was crawling with
spiders
we're about to face worse let's find
Sebastian quickly
revelio
[Music]
I don't think I need to do any of that
stuff this time Sebastian when you and
Anne found him just ahead in the great
room
[Music]
foreign
dude when they surround you in here
you can get tough fast
oh no
I shouldn't have done that
I shouldn't have done that okay this way
full and there's no signs
oh my goodness there's so many
no I died
all right
try again
the word this many in theory before
and there's no sign of Sebastian
I almost wonder if I should have all my
fire spells on one spot together
it's hit one with the ancient magic
let's get rid of you
yeah whoever said I need to upgrade the
ancient Magic
I think we've almost definitely need to
do that
[Music]
there we go got two of them with
incendio right there
I'm trying to save my Wigan Wells
because we only have eight
no
literally the moment I said I'm trying
to save my Wigan welds there we go
yeah I should probably be using defendo
more too
once we get them on fire
I wonder if I could just stay up here
will they run up here
let's find out it probably will but
oh wait wait wait maybe not
yes we got two right there
okay wait I have defendo on the left one
are you burning down there nope okay
let's ancient Magic
you're burning though so we should be
able to use
only 3.99 oh no
jeez three in a row
that I needed to do
no
all right I had to use one I had to use
it had to use it
there we go three right there
freedom
okay bombardo works when you already
have them on fire
but if you don't it doesn't do any
damage to the inferior
are you the last one I want to save my
try to save the ancient magic because
it's only going to get more difficult I
was so worried about Sebastian soon I
didn't even realize Anne's gone to get
something yeah we should get a death
counter
Sebastian was being attacked
but then he showed her the Relic and
said he'd learned how to use it carvings
on The Relic were in theory
and Sebastian somehow created them not
exactly he's controlling them
this is powerful dark magic creating in
theory is incredibly difficult but
controlling them as Anne and I
frantically barricaded the inferior to
keep them from escaping Sebastian kept
mumbling about healing Anne well Anna
said she couldn't stay here I didn't
realize what she meant Solomon
threatened to go to the Headmaster if he
heard of Sebastian dealing with dark
magic I need to get Hogwarts I must get
to Professor black first twist the story
bit make him think it's a family fight
I'll be back as soon as I can see if you
can talk some sense into Sebastian
oh boy
now ominous is leaving us
dude it's such Close Quarters too
all right I have I have to use it
and I don't think does crucio do
anything to them
did something
I mean I just don't know if you can
torture
and then Furious
okay wait this one's gonna be really
good to use on them too
there we go
oh yeah Shadow guided so
you have to make sure I don't know if
you if you made this mistake or not but
on the drops guys as you're earning them
you have to make sure that you go to the
twitch page and claim them so like once
you watch for 30 minutes you'll be able
to progress it but it won't start going
to the next one until you go and
specifically hit claim so even if you're
here watching for you know three four
hours whatever
you have to make sure you're hitting
hitting that claim after each one all
right there he is dude
oh man everybody's favorite thing for me
to try
messing with these bones here these
bones if you guys haven't seen some of
our streams with the these bones love me
man
they almost always
see if I can actually get them to work
properly the first time
okay we got that side now
oh did we actually get it first tried no
way
it's meant to be isn't this
dude they're so tall
Sebastian I told you the Relic is the
answer Perpetual fish
it is me the design
just as I can control the in theory
control just a dad who loves games
thank you
all right guys here we go
and no this is Lord retro more an evil
Slytherin indeed
[Music]
see I wish long I think something would
have been so awesome is if you had a
choice right here
obviously right now it doesn't really
matter because I'm on an evil
playthrough
but imagine if you if you even if you
didn't agree with Sebastian's uncle
you wouldn't want them fighting
so imagine if you could actually
choose to go against Sebastian during
this moment
I think that would have been really cool
hit him with an ancient magic actually I
meant to hit you Solomon
oh dude can we cast crucio on him oh he
dodged it
no way how about Imperial Solomon
oh he shakes It Off
oh that's so cool
that is lore accurate too
you know the stronger the mind the more
they would be able to resist
so with him being a former auror it
makes total sense
that he would be able to resist that
from a young wizard
can he shake off crucio
dude he's got a lot of Health all that
damage we've done we are on hard mode as
well so you know what let's get
uh we've got invisibility we've got
Thunder brew and we've got an adurus
let's release a cabbage
let them do some work here
we go yeah watch he's gonna shake it off
no not crucial on you
[Music]
no
okay we're still doing okay on health
right now
wait where did he go
what was that him that was him of course
I shouldn't have said anything about
doing okay on health
all right let's hit him with an ancient
Magic
oh that was big damage right there big
damage
I forgot to draw them in first
come on come on come on it's India there
we go
thank you
dude why is
Solomon's just like solely focused on me
oh that was big we had three of the men
right there
we're going on
I love these fights with the with other
really powerful Wizards I think they're
some of the best in the game
no
we still got quite a ways to go man I
think all right let's use that heel
and then I'm going to do a thunder Brew
[__] you
interior
there we go that was big damage right
there
and see the lightning is
keeping the inferior off at least a
little bit
Sebastian come on you got to keep those
inferior away from us
yeah we're getting close now
this might be it
there we go
Big Time damage
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
just like slightly
some people I saw were saying that he's
not he doesn't die instantly but I think
it was just like
his face relaxing as he fell
so
how does this play out man does after
this incredibly emotional moment does
Sebastian just walk out and straight up
be like
I will teach you AKA
this is such an emotional moment
and he's still like even now he doesn't
get it like he doesn't even have remorse
yet
made you a choice yeah she's oh she's
powerful she is really powerful and just
storms in there takes control of the
situation
oh and
what have you done
really Anne's the one you're asking what
have you done
yeah that's right Anna I've not I've not
seen how it plays out with the Vodka
Kadabra so I don't I don't know how we
learn it
I can't let him leave
[Music]
Sebastian wait
it's kind of awkward I'm I'm ahead of
you saying wait but here we are
here we are sir
this is the point you knew it was to
fart yeah for sure
Sebastian come back hold on
hold on doordash deliver from Cheeto
what
are you serious
I know Sammy and the music's so good
yeah let me let me grab those things on
the way out please hold on
assistant
why wouldn't you stop I was calling off
to you and won't survive this and then
even us why wouldn't you stop and out
the quiet the first question isn't why
did you do that he gave up on that
I'll never give up on her you saw him
didn't you he was going to ruin her life
he attacked us I
to killing curse you know I had if I had
to kill him what
everyone should know
he did that's right I'm Lord Rachel
Morton let's play through it was Brave
Sebastian
look at this grave
Uncle ever did I knew you'd understand
you did I would have done the same
if I knew how I could teach you
now is not the time
it's it's totally the time no time like
the present the killing curse won't be
easy to master
as with all unforgivables
you have to mean it
yes Savage it was uh it is live on the
official Hogwarts Legacy YouTube channel
the incantation we watched it at the
start of the stream today too your
intention must be clear if anybody
wanted to go back in the VOD
it's about uh nine ten minutes or so
yeah thank you forsaken for pointing
that out stay here
I need to find ominous wait do we do we
know it Sebastian
please I'm not myself right now did I
get let's meet later the undercroft okay
we did
all right so
oh dude we're gonna have to change our
setup
I'm gonna put it right there and then on
this one
let's go with
Expelliarmus over here
I might just leave it like that for now
or or
oh you know what maybe we go with one
that is all the unforgivables
what do you guys think Chad those of you
who have done a play through with
the unforgivables
do you like to have one like sort of in
each slot like I like I have set up here
or should I put all three of them in a
slot together
and then maybe one more spell that kind
of complements them
Christy I did a full wheel and I had
them all together one wheel okay seems
like everybody is uh
seems like everybody's in agreement that
see I I was thinking like maybe it would
be best to try to pair them with other
things that they would work well with
together
but yeah now I kind of like I I'm sort
of leaning to what you guys are saying
all right so let's go back here let's
put Expelliarmus here like we had it and
then let's go to this one I feel like AK
on Square
imperio there
crucio there on Circle
all right so now do I have anything not
mapped
okay we've got
all right that's good we've got one of
each yellow mapped
foreign oh I don't have bombardo mapped
so let's go ahead and we'll just map
bombardo there for now
I mean we might change it up again once
we get arresto and flippindo
Actually I don't even know if I'll need
to learn those on this playthrough
AKA a person first
you learned it in the under crop yeah I
guess if you say to him
that now's not a good time then he'll
teach you back there
you had them on the bottom wheel yeah
Craig that's where I got mine I don't
know why the bottom wheel I normally
just use for
like all of these things lumos and stuff
like that
don't cast it on an animal use a person
as the first kill split that Soul
oh man
I hate that it's come to this Sebastian
imagine
all right
now
let us see if we go to our quests page
here
craft the Keeper's wand that's what we
need to do
all right and that only requires level
24 so let's go ahead and do that how
cool would it be if you could learn more
Ultra
see was that I mean was that a thing
before Voldemort's time though that's
the question right
and is that spell
like like what does that spell truly do
does it specifically create that design
that Mark I mean because of course
they're going to be other spells that
can
create
you know Illusions or light whatever I'm
not sure exactly what the
properties of that Essence would be just
magical Essence in the sky
but is that one specific to the dark
mark because olivanders
I think it probably is right
Mars mantra
oh but I do like your idea though cast
That cast something like the dark mark
and then dark Wizards would show up to
help that would be crazy
a double Imperial oh wait do I
no no I'm good
see we got one of each oh yeah we still
we just have on our left and right we do
have a
we still have them on the left but I
don't have anything else to put there
right now anyway so
I mean unless I put like one of the
essential spells or not the essential
spells but like lumos or something
or one of the Transfiguration
hello Mr olivanda I wondered if you
might be able to help me with something
yeah
Professor figs sent an owl informing me
that you'd be coming he was a bit
cryptic said you need to have a special
wand crafted that you'd I did just learn
about I hope that's okay I have the man
oh my is that it's not going to be a
problem
remarkable design I will be honest I
have never crafted a wand in this
fashion repaired broken ones of course
but this is
something else entirely keeping me on my
toes aren't you I think I can work we
are indeed
let me see what I can do
yeah this part was pretty cool
I just wish the wand had had more
use than it actually did you know
but they also that's that's tough to do
with with lore and everything right
because if they let our character get a
one at the beginning of the game that
chooses us then it's kind of weird if we
get another one here
that becomes our new wand so this one
just has its own
special property
there it is
ancient magic wand I should warn you
I've never seen a one like this before
my suspicion as Professor fig implied in
his letter is that it serves a unique
purpose
I doubt you shall find much use for it
otherwise
I understand thank you sir keep the
aesthetic on R1 instead of making a
brain wait does this act it doesn't
actually become your wand does it
am I completely misremembering that
I'm afraid you're on your own
I've ensured that we have a moment to
ourselves
yes you have still got my regular one
right there
in light of what ranrock now knows you
must agree that our interests are alive
okay yeah our interests will never be
aligned
you would let goblins take what is
rightfully ours
the final repository belongs to wizard
kind
belongs to me not to work together Lord
retro Mort
thank you guys for the new follows by
the way welcome in
Big Moment In the game uh we are near
the end near the end
Mutual Pursuit
I have no idea what you're talking about
it's repository is my Birthright
he mad
greloisten should follow better than to
try and reason child
I've always said
children
should be seen and not heard
hold up
oh dude we got can we
we did just learn AK I don't think we
can use it on him though can we oh wait
before we before we do this fight can I
upgrade my talent yes okay we have one
Talent Point available I'm gonna go
right into the dark arts here this one
killing an enemy with a vodka diver
kills all cursed enemies
all right where you guys at you guys
don't even know what's coming here
you don't even know what's coming
all right so that just took out three of
them right there because of that upgrade
[Music]
no
foreign
they're probably starting to wear off
the cooldown now yeah we need that guy
on Imperial
all right let's go ahead and use
I'm gonna heal and then use a duras
all right I gotta start using Stupify
man
I'm just gonna wait just wait
get rid of you
all right look how many we have cursed
right now
dude and we almost have AK ready to go
we're gonna be able to take out so many
oh that was big right there
yes
dude that is crazy powerful
crazy powerful man
oh no
oh frames frames frames
oh no I wanted to cast it on you
see I need to cast the Stupify because
it will curse even more of them every
time
[Music]
and then as soon as we get AK ready to
go again
uh
almost
maybe five more seconds
there it is
that should have gotten all of them yep
that is so ridiculously powerful man
I just launched into the sky
that was crazy
country tickets
okay we still got a while on AK now
dude we need Imperial on this guy
he has a lot of Health
they have so much health too man
enough
what I cast Expelliarmus on you
dude I'm trying to save these all right
[Music]
okay get rid of the ash Winder assassin
we do have an AK ready
all right let's cast it on you
and then we're ready for an Avada
stop hitting me with that
wait I thought that guy was gonna be
one heal man I don't like this
all right let's see do we have anything
in here we can use no
look at this
watching those of you that actually move
around wait what do you how do you how
do you fight Justice you don't you don't
move around in the game
I just need to start mastering my
protego I don't know why I'm not doing
it more it's so powerful
get over here and help me dude
thank you
like what you're under Imperial go get
him
he's just standing there
there we go
oh X this time
yeah I think I agree Magicka they
definitely kind of want you to move
around to collect the
no more of them
I cannot use this last one man
I need to get a few more under Stupify
now
yes there we go there we go
Circle this time
you're glitching out of bounds Shadow
guided on on this game are you in a
different game
I wish we would have actually gotten to
duel him
like one-on-one once we cleared out all
the other ones you know
finally over
to send an alternate right away
but now though I need to get back
I think what's happened
back to the map chamber
all right dude look at off this loot
around oh you're on this and you're
glitching out
Rebellion
I knew there was a chest over here
somewhere
wait how do I get you
how do I get you
we go outside for that one
oh yeah it's in the tent here
thank you guys for the new follows
welcome in
appreciate you all being here and
hanging out today
the drops are live and active
if you guys have any questions about
them exclamation point drops in the chat
we'll get you the info you need
see if we missed anything
I see a couple more items over here
a charcoal lock scarf
there's one right there
I think the poaching air inserts have
spiders it's all worth the trouble of
yours I heard something wait how do I
get in there is it from this direction
Rebellion
there it is
I knew I was like there's a reason it's
not checked it off yet
all right I mean we're already flying I
might as well grab these while we're
here right
wait why are these here right now
troubles brewing and I'm without my
friends
I don't remember the little yellow
bubbles being out when it's just normal
like this
oh I missed one at the beginning didn't
I
Rebellion
wait why didn't it
is there one more missing
down low Maybe
oh it's an assignment okay so did I just
they just mess it up by doing
part of it right there hopefully it'll
respawn
all right let's go back to Fig you know
it regenerates okay good good good
back to Professor fig in the secret map
chamber underneath Hogwarts
as asgrim welcome in thank you for the
follow
we are very close to the final mission
guys
Victor Rookwood is dead
he confronted me as I left olivanders
with the Keeper's wand
I had to defend myself godric's heart
are you all right I know you're well
able what is the broom
I've seen it off hold on one second I'll
pull it up here himself
cat what he deserved he destroyed so
many lives and he wouldn't have stopped
I'm glad I was able to put an end to him
you're right he wouldn't have stopped
you did what you had to do
The Wizarding Community owes you a great
debt thank you for saying so professor
I'm ready for what's next all right then
the keepers have been waiting
you have completed all of our trials and
you have done so under circumstances
even I did not foresee you understand
now why they still trust me yes they
don't know about the unforgivable side
the book
the trials to ensure that one with the
ability you and I share would make the
same choice that son Eve Charles and I
did
now that you have witnessed my memory
you understand all that is at stake
not everyone is what they seem
as you know light does not exist without
see I thought that was hinting at some
big twist
simply because you can eliminate
Darkness does not always mean that you
should
even the most well-meaning and competent
amongst us cannot possibly know the
consequences of manipulating what should
be beyond our reach what lies in the
repository must never yeah they
definitely don't get out much the
temptation to destroy or control it the
magic that you have so carefully honed
must now be used only
the secret we keep
you have the wand
you will know when to wield it we leave
our Legacy in your hands
oh boy
if only you knew what you just
you just did Percival
astonishing
Repository
[Music]
the music
we can only hope that we're not too late
and that we find nothing but a
repository undisturbed Beyond this door
there's this right here
special version of zenobius
oh yeah you want to check me to check
that broom too let me see what broom
that is
that broom is the Ember Dash broom
the Ember Dash broom
all right the keepers Caverns
I don't know if I should do this without
upgrading but we're gonna try
we're gonna try to just go straight in
hey appreciate that bad kitty always
loved your streams glad I could catch
them today super excited for the drops
yeah they're actually
I think it's some of the best cosmetics
in the game I can assure you they will
in the future they are pretty good reach
Professor Weasley
because we'll arrive soon oh no they
know where to find the door through
which we are I wonder if I can actually
turn back
we should have created a save back there
we've got like five this could be really
bad man we have no plants
a few wig and weld potions and that is
pretty much it
gonna be putting my skills to the test
guys okay nine wiggin welds we are on
hard mode only two ancient magic meters
it cannot be far
but we do have all the unforgivables
locked in and ready to go
man imagine what
big would be thinking you run in here
and you're just like
crucio
Imperial
and then he sees you do that
oh he didn't even say anything
[Music]
the problem is I just take so much
damage from these hits
nothing
I mean we've only been hit one time but
here we go
we'll refill right there no plants look
at that we've got nothing okay we have
one invisibility potion
but those things aren't aren't really
all that helpful
one moment
let's go
this part was so cool man
and all the other teachers show up here
I know what we're gonna
get a gap
yeah go get him troll
foreign
to help
actually you know what let's just go
ahead and do this if that takes out both
trolls
dude that is so powerful
that upgrade
yourself
wait why can I not
what
I can't lock onto this guy
okay there fig took care of him
he was under imperio for a bit
yeah we upgraded our gear last time I
probably should have done it right
before this actually you know what one
thing I can do
as I can check and see if we have any
any upgrades waiting for us right now
okay that would be plus two defense not
worth it
uh we don't we can't do any of those
uh oh those are downgrades
that's a downgrade
and that we can't if oh my gosh
well we tried potterhead we tried
more wig and weld that's good that's
good I feel right professor
there's nothing we can do but keep
searching
lumos
more we can weld nice all right I'm glad
I didn't waste time going and brewing a
lot of wig and whales before this
looks like they include plenty in
dude
you just watched the chaos man
come on I need to I want to do nope not
that one
hit me normally
oh fig that was some nice nice combo
right there
working together
the glacias defendo combo
I can't lock onto that guy whenever he
uh
I don't know if that's a glitch or not
okay now we can lock onto him
once imperio wears off these tunnels
haven't brought as much luck so far
welcome into the new followers thank you
all for being here
we are currently in the final Story
Mission of the game
look at all these Wicked worlds
[Music]
more trolls
I think I saw three right there
yes this part is so good
all of them arrive except Professor
garlic
and of course no Professor black
maybe garlic is
protecting all the students
oh and black of course is hiding I got
this
[Music]
garlic is garlic is a Sith Lord yeah
she's gonna turn on everybody in
Hogwarts Legacy too
the music's so good too look at heckett
thank you three of them at once
[Music]
wait did I miss one with imperio or did
I just actually cast it on the same one
no none of that
there we go
[Music]
what
it's supposed to go through the shields
that dude just survived AK
a all right hit someone that I couldn't
see behind him
[Music]
foreign
it comes back super quick
this one's worse than the last two okay
then he's a perfect one for Imperials
dude it's just so overpowered
pretty good
all right I'll use one wig and weld
right there although I do want to save
most of them for the final fight
look how fast that Shield comes back oh
oh oh oh oh oh okay he's mad now
hit him with imperio again
and now watch this
yes NJ buff get your Twitch drops
which drops here and enabled
exclamation point drops in the chat you
guys have any questions or need the link
it will get you the information you need
Weasley got our back
that's how I went forward
[Music]
all right so far having the
unforgivables has made this part even on
hard mode relatively
easy I know the final fight's gonna be
tough
especially without having any we don't
have any extra stuff
so it's pretty much just going to be wig
and Weld and our spells
all right let's do this fig
I feel sorry for the trolls they have no
stake in this right
just manipulated by I assume ran Rock to
there
they're under his control
that grin dude
my guy looks so uh unsure
hey Chandler wood
is up Chandler
stop by to get your drops I know man
that's crazy you don't get they don't
hook you up with those
I gotta say I love I love ronan's attire
though
it looks really good
really good guys say hello to Chandler
wood in the chat
Community manager over at Avalanche
software
we watched the Tom Felton video earlier
that was that was good stuff man good
stuff
I loved how he he got legitimately
emotional
at that um in the common room moment
and Ellen of course gifting out a sub to
Chandler right there you love to see it
no ads for you now Chandler
Miriam believe this forgotten magic
could be used for such good
but she did not know the risks that's
right Patrick see what the keepers have
shown you
what is a Dora showed you you are now
the keeper of whatever power it holds
what do you intend to do with it
oh okay so here's the choice right
all right so this is our evil
playthrough we do not want to keep it
contained
we absolutely want to open it
I have decided to open the Repository
power cannot lie dormant for centuries
big how's it going to take this
everything you've seen
what about isadora's fate
okay then this is like the secondary
choice
uh you're right this power should not be
kept or you're right option two this
power should not be kept from the world
option three I want the power for myself
oh you guys already know Lord retro Mort
can feel I mean he's so close
he can feel it at this point guys
he absolutely wants the power for
himself
yes Nikki the the video is on YouTube it
is on the official Hogwarts Legacy
YouTube channel
should be their most recent video it's
about a 9 10 minutes of Tom Felton
playing through some of the Sebastian
sallow quest line
all right I want the power for myself
is a Dora wasted her ability trying to
save people for themselves look at his
face dude others dictate what I do with
this
my
power you cannot possibly mean that you
of all wizards are aware of the misery
and that would have been crazy
wait I don't know maybe we do
no okay so ran all right ran Rock still
shows up arrogance of wizard kind
welcome in to all the new follows by the
way
belongs to us enough Round Rock who is
never yours
I've been wanting to play with this
Miriam's wand
if she'd simply well fake man container
when you make this decision oh could
have been avoided
foolish
self-important witch
seems you're two are kind
she didn't know when to give up either
I mean this dude has spent this whole
entire school year trying to teach us
about why
we shouldn't open this thing and we're
like nah I'm opening it
and actually I don't want to even try to
do good with it I just want it for
myself
tough man
oh Potter head I don't know what
happened you might have tried to spam
too many emotes
maybe one of the mods can help
see what uh see what was going on there
[Music]
thank you Jamie I appreciate it
I'm not sure what got flagged in by the
Auto mod
all right
here we go guys hardest fight in the
game by far
we are on hard mode
I don't even know if the unforgivables
are going to be of any use to us at all
here
all right there we go
we probably need just damage spells
yeah
oh my goodness I'm not even gonna waste
wig and welds on this one because I'm
just I'm just assuming I'm gonna die on
the first time first attempt
I just want to see how much different it
is on hard mode yeah I gotta be ready
for that
okay then we gotta switch to something
that we can actually hit him with
yeah
so like bombardo okay yeah bombarda does
pretty well
and then confringo
so let's see bombarda confringo
I might want to put though like just for
this specific mission
all right chat tell me can you use
are the unforgivables of any use in this
battle
because I don't think they are
so if that's the case I might just go
but this one right here we've got
bombarded there on the bottom
you don't think so we haven't tried it
okay
[Music]
what he would transfigure to if the
spell worked
imagine okay defindo might might work to
do some damage on him
all right so we've got bombard at the
bottom
let's go
confringo here
the findo there
and then we'll have Expelliarmus I don't
know if that'll do anything
yeah yeah I know about the R1 yeah I was
just kind of experimenting there to see
I mean AK is definitely not going to do
anything Imperial is definitely not
going to do anything the only one that
would have a chance of doing anything
would probably be crucio
all right let's have crucio there we'll
test it out here
all right so that's on our bottom okay
thinking of the power from the
repository
and of course there's multiple phases to
this fight too
all right so now oh see you gotta be
ready
oh
it actually did
I mean it put the curse effect on him
anyway there we go hit him with those oh
it missed
no way
all right one thing we have to work on
though is we have to hit
we have to hit all of the
protagos
ah then I do it right there
there we go
why am I not using protego because I
keep thinking it's gonna be that one
right there that's why
oh ain't your magic
oh I can't do it on that one
all right I'm gonna actually use a wig
and weld
does right there
all right we got to the next the next
section
12 Wigan welds
not great
I know when you're on hard mode just
like one hit and you are
you are in trouble okay I guess we have
to go over here
[Music]
don't stop me
that's what I just have to do that every
time
no
about that very much
I've gotta start hitting that man
because that does I think that does the
most damage out of anything actually
no no no
oh and it puts you back at the beginning
I think
j95 yes you made it just in time all
right so we had we were down to 12 Wigan
Wells let's see what it puts us at
I wasn't ready for this okay good so it
puts us at this part
that's not gonna be too bad then
I was thinking we had to do that whole
first part again
and it does reset our wig and welds too
there's a wig and weld oh somewhere out
here
Akio
okay this is not a good start
to see if glacias actually
does anything to him
like that right there I gotta be ready
for that
I know I keep saying it I hope that I
keep saying it at some point it will
sink into me
thank you
[Music]
no wrong spell wrong spell again
that's the one I'm looking for
oh
all right we have got to make sure that
we're getting those R1 so when he does
that it's either
if he does like the flame like the
breath you just have to dodge that but
if he does
the other you either can protego and
stupefy back or you can use R1 ancient
Magic
how did that hit me I think I timed it a
little too early
[Music]
cm2 distracted
foreign
try a little glacias before
no
oh see I knew I knew I would push the
wrong one
that's probably why I just
more often than not I'm just dodging
there we go
there it is a rock
oh but we missed it I think that one's
even more power no just when we had an
ancient magic ready
crucio has no effect well he's it's it's
putting the curse on him though is it
not does it not actually matter
you know what puts the curse effect on
him because you see the green eggs
but if you guys are saying it doesn't
actually matter then that's a different
story
no wrong one
might as well need to reset this
is
oh I've gotta get that one dude
okay let's see
like see it definitely reaches him
because he gets the little green X
[Music]
thank you
oh I don't have one ready I don't have
one ready
no not descendo over there
no
so we know crucio reaches him though
guys because it here let's test it let's
test it I'm not gonna cast any other
spell
the the way that we know it reaches him
is because
it puts the curse effect on you see the
green
oh
okay then the red one
all right watch this
oh it did I mean yeah I saw 75.
I saw 74 c c 74
chat
you guys trying to Lead Me Wrong Man
I'm just kidding I appreciate the help
but yeah that was the only spell I cast
so it absolutely has an effect
[Music]
yes right there
that's no
no
hit another crucio on you
[Music]
okay see sometimes you can't actually
fire it back that I do not understand
oh I can't believe that killed me
that's at least like four or five deaths
on him I don't know we haven't been
keeping track
thank you
I don't like that very much
like oh it's so annoying
all right I'm about to get so annoyed
with myself
maybe I need I need to back up that's
another key
[Music]
oh there it was yes we got one can we
get another
[Music]
I should probably heal
oh that was big damage right there
big damage
and I see the ancient Magic Orb out
there I'm gonna make a break for it
he'll heal
why did I miss that
all right we're so close man we're so
close
ancient Magic
there we go
next phase
see I knew as soon as we just started
hitting those ancient magic throws
that we would be able to get him
[Music]
recommended not for fanatics What's that
question mean
like the game recommend the game
[Music]
if you're talking about recommend the
game oh yeah you don't have to be a
die-hard Harry Potter fan to enjoy this
I don't think so
oh we can't hit it from there
why is it
thank you
oh there's one there's one there's one I
missed it though can we get that one in
time yes
oh dude his health at this stage though
his health man
sheesh
oh we got one way over here
oh no
[Music]
oh he was a direct hit dude his health
is ridiculous right now
like see why can I not throw that one
back
I'm gonna try not to I'm gonna try not
to
okay I'm not
oh
dude his it just takes so long right now
to actually damage him
no wrong one
there's a rock
yeah the Rocks do pretty good
[Music]
that totally missed
I knew there was one more somewhere
all right hey with crucio and then let's
hit him with all three of the okay
that's just not fair
oh dude this is bad we're not gonna
survive this
I don't think we're gonna have a chance
we just I can't do enough damage to him
why can I not
okay ancient magic please do some good
damage on him
I hope it did more than what I just saw
because that barely did anything
oh this could be really bad if we die
here
no no
all right the question is how far back
does it put us
and how much
Wigan will do they give us
if it puts us right there in that
section with only three winged welds oh
my God
this is bad you guys
this is really bad
let me listen
[Music]
now
okay that's ridiculous if that still
hits me
well we gotta hit him with that
he just has so much health at this stage
and this goes back pretty far too
oh man you guys we might have to like
reload a previous save or something
get a few more wig and well potions
no
we have to hit him with all of those
I'm not even gonna waste my wig and
welds I'm just practicing right now we
know we're not gonna
we're probably not going to survive this
if I get his health pretty low then
yeah I was gonna say if I get him low
I'll consider using a Wigan weld
right it's like there's a perfect
distance Magica you're right where you
can okay just fly right in and do that
to me all right
because you have to be able to hit the
spells that you need
like that right there
I mean I still don't think the game's
hard enough Anna this this is just a big
spike in difficulty on this one even in
even in normal a lot of people said this
was like a big spike in difficulty
thank you
stop me
[Music]
oh come on you gotta reach
oh geez you should not be able to hit me
with that
I tried pushing R1
right there I need that
okay 409 on that
all right that was actually decent
damage I'm gonna use a wig and weld
foreign
[Music]
right there yes
big damage on that
last weekend well maybe it's worth it
come on
yeah that's oh another rock
oh I missed that one
I definitely do better like when I have
a little bit of distance between us ooh
there's a big rock
[Music]
oh we're so close man
we're so close
right there
let's go
[Music]
foreign
still not done
no wrong spell
no not like this
we were that close
you guys
we were that close to dying right there
do you imagine
the role the confringo
just in time
see I knew we didn't need all those
potions
I knew we didn't need those plants
we got this
take that power oh the red eyes he's got
the red eyes now
that needs to be the thumbnail for my
final playthrough
just that I need to get that screenshot
with the red eyes
[Music]
oh man look at that
open the Repository
[Music]
all right so if you guys have seen the
good ending
notice the difference here
there's a there's an absence of
something significant
happening on this one
[Music]
I know he says thank you Miriam for
everything like like that's what she
would have wanted
oh exactly Anna exactly he does not
appear
when you choose to
take the power
Professor Eleazar fig it's just so
awkward now after the choice we just
made
a meeting colleague to his peers we just
went against what he wanted
both discretion and we feel no shame
providing perhaps a rather unfortunate
lesson for us all is Devotion to
Adventure was rivaled only by his
dedication to Hogwarts and of course to
his wife Maddie
um she's like all right let me let me
take care of this much too
really Simeon are you sure he should be
there yeah you should have one more
representative if you make the good of
all of us to keep the repositories uh
safe not open it or whatever
he has one little final appearance there
at the end or should anyway what's the
[Music]
what's the perhaps it was his remarkable
courage for which we will all be forever
indebted to him
if not for Professor fig
well
I can say with confidence that if not
for him many of us
let alone Hogwarts would not be here
today
those that knew him best will agree that
we must now honor him as only Hogwarts
can
by
wisely
resourcefully
justly
and bravely facing all that lies ahead
to Professor fig
I just realized I don't have the wand
wand up emote here
that's a that's a YouTube only
I didn't know him as well as you did but
I know he was a good man Brad Weasley
spoke for him she honored him well fig
will be well remembered
I
realize the same should be done for my
uncle
I hope Anna Grace to see me Sebastian
I can't imagine what you and Anne are
going through
perhaps you'll hear from us soon I hope
so
I I'll let you know Sebastian
there's something you should know
it's to do with Victor Rookwood I hope
yeah that he confronted you outside of
Oliver they're big sounds as if you
piece of info here the rumors are true
and I did but it's not that
just before Rook would attacked he
uttered something familiar the same
words Anne heard before she was cursed
children should be seen and not heard
wait what what are you saying he wasn't
one of ranrock's loyalists who kirstan
it was Rookwood it was Rookwood all
along this this can't be
it was the Loyalists it's always been
them
the night and was cursed all she saw
were goblins once Rook would allied with
ran Rock Isidore's estate became of
interest to them both that's why
Rookwood was there the night and was
cursed he was working with ranrock when
he saw your sister well he didn't want
anyone to know so he cursed her and
she's never been the same
so cruel
Rookwood deserved what he got thank you
for telling me
it wasn't a goblin
I suppose I owe you an apology all this
time I thought goblins were the enemy
but it was never that simple as for what
happened in the catacomb
I've not stopped thinking about it
perhaps we could meet soon
there's much I wish to say
all right and then we need to get the uh
this cutscene here
and then there's the bit about the owls
wow but that's it you guys
congratulations you have completed the
story of Hogwarts Legacy and reached the
end of your school year with your owl
exams fast approaching now is a good
time to review your Field Guide progress
explore the world finish any remaining
relationship storylines in side quests
and complete your Field Guide as you see
fit and go for the platinum trophy wait
what wait
oh man guys if you're watching this on
YouTube thank you all so much for being
here hope you've enjoyed this series as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon